I always think about what I do for a
living which is I have this need for
some reason to disproportionately
disproportionately over share what's
working for me quickly at scale yeah and
I think through the Karma points
whatever you know all this money I leave
on the table plays out in perpetuity
because I think I'm talented enough to
grab it yeah and I and I also don't
really have a model that's more on my
audience it's more I have separate
companies and and it's funny I didn't
even think this we were hanging out
because Dustin is 12 minutes late with
it but if he didn't have an exploding
stomach oh and a foot so I was thinking
about this I wasn't thinking about this
before but literally as this has just
started the thing that came to my mind
is one of things I've always really
respected about you raised that I really
remember vividly that you were one of
the first people I remembered like I'm
like oh she's actually executing on what
I'm saying and every time I hang out
with her whether I come to some weird
apartment in New York where's her studio
is or if I see her in LA at her house or
randomly she's thoughtful
she's thoughtfully look like like I
think she this was almost like a
compliment to myself slashed to you I'm
being serious yeah I remember I feel it
right now I vividly remember thinking
I'm like oh she knows that I'm up to
something yeah she's listening yeah but
unlike 99.9 percent she's then executing
and in a lot of ways you would have done
I never existed you would be exactly
where you are but there has always been
a little bit of a nice feeling in my
stomach because I think you really
listened and you execute it always I
mean that's the thing I have my head
down more than anything else you know
and I love who you are I love what you
do and somebody said this to me last
night on my tour stop they're like
you're you're really generous and I'm
like I just give a [ __ ] I give lots of
[ __ ] and I care and when people around
me that I see are doing great work I
want to do everything I can to spread
their message so when your books came
out or something knew you were doing and
I said hey I have a platform it might
not be the same size or scale as yours
but it's different and I want to expose
people to great ideas that they can
actually use to improve their business
in life and that's my goal in life yep
and so
minutes of context cuz I want to do
hardcore I want to do two things for you
to tell the audience now about yourself
yes some don't know yep I want you to
tell everybody about the book yeah
because one thing I'm proud of is unlike
me who doesn't learn more an audio and
visual a lot of my audience learns from
reading and yeah I think books are
inexpensive for the ROI for people that
learn that way I can never read a book
on the record but everyone learns
different and the number three I wanna
go into questions once you frame up
those two things yeah I want people to
call in put in your phone number go to
LinkedIn if you're not on there if you
want to ask a question or keep watching
on whatever stream you're watching right
now putting your phone number of
questions raghava is going through those
as we speak but I want the questions to
be a little bit predicated on what
you're about to frame up so who are you
and then what's this book about yeah
so for me entrepreneur author and I like
giving back so I say philanthropist not
in the way that I'm Warren Buffett but
in the way that I like to use my
resources my platform my financial
resources to aim it towards things I
feel that we should improve in this
world in some small way so I started off
my journey on the floor of the New York
Stock Exchange I have a lot of energy I
knew I could never sit behind the desk
but about six months into that job and
what year was that that was like 1998
and and just knowing the culture of Wall
Street to begin with yeah and then
obviously America thank God starting to
progress a little bit in boy-girl
conversations yep that must have been a
real Baptist but I mean I can't even
imagine like I'm like the sheer amount
of politically incorrect things that
must have happened to you within the
first week oh I mean I was battling
constantly it was like hey do you want
to hang out it was after work strip
clubs
oh do you mean no no I get it I have
long hair I actually cut off all my hair
to be exactly like yours because I tried
to get taken more seriously
that's how much I see for that so I
started hearing this voice inside that
was like Marie you are not meant to do
this outside of all that [ __ ] yeah
because you could you knew what you were
getting yourself into it and you could
handle the boys club things wholly I
knew that I knew there was other things
going completely one of the things that
was a clue was that a lot of you in some
weird way seed the advantage of that
like did like not meaning like the
cliche thing that somebody might have
just thought of like you're using your
girl power and add more of because you
could handle it yeah and you understood
it yeah you could professionally
navigate it Oh completely well I'm tough
right I'm very very
but I'm also very tough yes I want what
I want and whatever I need to do in
order to achieve and grow and experience
what I want to experience I'm willing to
put myself through so that was not a
problem but I also have a really strong
sense of intuition and when something's
not right my body revolts yeah literally
on the floor of the exchange because I'd
been ignoring this voice I'd like Marie
you're not supposed to be here this is
not your life path one day I walked into
my job and I started having only what I
can identify as like a little mini panic
attack yeah he's like feeling like [ __ ]
yeah I told my boss hey I need to go get
some coffee
I made a beeline to the nearest church
because I graduated from Seton Hall
University so I was kind of trained in a
crisis to look up and ask for help
so I'm sitting on the church steps
bawling my eyes out feeling out the
Biggest Loser because I'm the first in
my family to go to college my parents
busted their ass to get me an education
their high school educated and Here I am
wanting to quit a stable job with health
benefits and all this stuff that's you a
very important question directly now
let's do were you a huge Terry - hair
fan I don't even know who that is I'm so
pissed right number okay I'm going very
nerdy Seton Hall basketball uh era yes
you clearly did not go deep enough into
the Pirates from 94 to 98 listen very
bad right so here's what I was doing
give me your bartending and waiting
tables and [ __ ] just being hustling
you focus I was but you didn't know
there was a good basketball of course I
did
so I'm crying on the church steps and I
pull out my flip phone because that's
what we had back then and I call my dad
because I felt so guilty I didn't want
to disrespect my parents and quit this
job when I don't have any other way of
living and I was certainly not gonna go
back home and my dad told me one of the
most important things I've ever heard he
said look you've worked since you were
nine years old I am not worried about
you keeping a roof over your head or
putting food on the table but you are
gonna work for the next 40 50 years at
least if you don't find something that
you love so much you're gonna be
miserable good so quit this job take as
long as you need to find that thing that
you feel you're meant to do and it's all
gonna come together so that permission
slip for me sent me on an odyssey to
figure out who the hell I was and what I
was meant to do all I knew was that I
was highly creative and I also loved
business but those two things didn't
seem to mesh back then like I originally
wanted to be an animator for Disney or a
fashion designer and I also loved my dad
was a small
business owner I love the way he treated
his customers it was a printing business
I would go in weekends and nights to
work with him and just loved his work
ethic that's what inspired me so I tried
magazine publishing I was in condé nast
publications in the ad sales department
I was like okay this is new this is
amazing
six months in those voices came back
like this is still not what you're meant
to do and I started panicking because I
felt like a loser I was like I'm so
ambitious I want to make money I want to
make a difference but I [ __ ] hate
what I'm doing and I looked ahead and I
said do I want to actually be the
publisher like do I want to climb this
moral ladder no I said well what am I
wasting my time in there time for I said
maybe I'm still too on the business side
numbers heavy let me try something more
creative like the editorial side I
hustled my way into getting a job as a
fashion editorial assistant at
Mademoiselle magazine I'm like this has
got to be it I'm going a fashion show
they're highly creative working on photo
shoots this is gonna be amazing
to cut to six months and that's exactly
right and I was like what now I really
started to panic because every single
one of my friends they were getting
raises promotions like starting an adult
life and here I was like feeling like
the biggest loser I graduated the
valedictorian and yet I can't seem to
hold down a job because I keep quitting
one day I was on the internet when I
probably shouldn't have been and I
stumbled upon this new profession at the
time was an article I read and it was
about coaching which again I'm no 23 in
my mind I'm saying this is the cheesiest
dumbest thing you've ever came across
who the hell's gonna hire 23 old life
coach you're a loser
you've got mountains of debt what are
you thinking and yet in my heart
something said this is who you are I
signed up for a three-year coach
training program at night and my studies
at night worked at Mademoiselle during
the day I get a call from the HR
department we have a promotion for you
going to vogue more money more prestige
more everything that was my fork in the
road to say okay are you gonna stay on
the safe path with the health benefits
people understand what you do for a
living it's respectable all that could
[ __ ] or quit and start this weird
coaching business at 23 which you have
no idea how to do your mountains and
mountains in debt and nobody even
understands what this is so I quit my
steady job I went back to bartending and
waiting tables and I spent
next seven years figuring out how to
build a coaching business from the
ground up so that's a very long story
how much were you worried about the
stigma of the bad coaching environment
well that didn't exist yet because I was
in early the only people that existed in
the space were basically Tony Robbins
yep that was the only known figure at
that time but there was stigma about I
mean even that mewho
oh absolutely know that I kind of
overrode that what my incident just were
like this is what I got to do yeah but I
was also in I was insecure about my age
yep but I had hit so many walls failing
on Wall Street failing and publishing
you're trying all these different things
that I was like well [ __ ] it if none of
those things work I have to try this
because a it feels right and B what are
my other options just to jump way up
today yes there's something I've been
thinking about this because I put a lot
of pressure in my opinion of like my own
concerns of the deep coaching and
mastermind ecosystem I hate it how do
you have to I don't know this I feel
like you'll have an answer for me yeah
has there been conversations of the
evolution of that where where the most
advanced and progressive and kind
strategists and coaches and masterminds
have talked about the notion of giving
people money back and not letting people
in like the only way to offset this
model yeah is to actually so many people
bottom feed and they know it yes this is
my problem this is why I never wanted to
monetize my audience this is why I could
probably build the biggest one I don't
have it yeah is because I don't want to
put in the time to refund or vet I don't
think I'm good at vetting yeah I'm gonna
firing yep but I'm not good at vetting
yep
and I think the way the coaching
mastermind industry needs to evolve is
not bottom feed and I think 80% of the
economics are built on that yeah in the
macro yep has there been any talk about
that you know it's just a moment or just
not yet I don't know if it's been yet
but here's what I did for my own self
and maybe this can be instructive so
after I built skills as a coach working
with people one on one which by the way
I did for free for so long because
that's how you win and listen i bartend
and waiting tables to put a roof over my
head so I could just deliver value to
people and improve my ability to help
them create change without any
expectation value
practice was there for you correct I got
so here's my model now I don't work with
people one on one I don't do masterminds
I don't do any of that [ __ ] but I love
education though because like books are
a form of Education all that stuff so
the flagship program that we have which
is called b-school here's how I operate
it because I hate all that [ __ ] we have
a refund policy that we've always had if
you actually go into the program and you
show us that you've done the coursework
in two weeks if you hate it you think we
[ __ ] suck we give you a hundred
percent here that's the way you hedged
it absolutely get it make sense me and
so I want to play with people who
actually want to learn I want to apply
knowing that a lot of people who know
you for that talk to me let's just skip
over yeah talk to me about what this
books about so everything is figure out
Abel or is a three word phrase that has
been the single most powerful driving
force in my life got me out of a toxic
relationship in high school helped me
get out of debt help me get every job
I've ever had helped me build the
company I have today which for me is my
ideal company I love what we do
it is a simple phrase that helps people
ignite their innate wisdom and do
anything they want to [ __ ] do in this
world and what about from a business
standpoint is this I don't know this
yeah is this the first third it is the
second book I wrote a book like over a
decade ago that was honestly like so
published or published by someone all
three I started off this as an e-book
when nobody even knew with me books were
like a PDF my book was like mind-blowing
then I self-published it and I went to
like I didn't do vanity [ __ ] I actually
see the first one an e-book yeah go the
route that everybody got caught in back
then that it was super expensive or no
it was $19 understood it was like that's
about was my first experience actually
Gary bartending like I went to a
bartending shift I worked my tail off
down downtown and I came home and
somebody bought my e-book from Spain and
I was like I could make a difference to
someone on the other side of the world
that I had never met yes that was your
second book the first one was what the
first one was called make every man want
you or make yours want you more how do
you know how to be so irresistible
you'll barely keep from dating yourself
it was funny it's in 16 languages but
after I said really your coming-out
party this is Norway in a big way so
this but wouldn't this come out this
came out on Tuesday we just got named
apples one of their
best books of September and they're most
recommended listen or download from the
audio version
did you read yes of course I have
scripted straight you know there's parts
in there I have a character named Jersey
Marie because I'm from Jersey and she
it's real rough and it's so you go oh of
course for the Jersey Marie parts before
we go into questions were about to yeah
to state of the union things that have
your attention
yeah in culture okay it could be yep yep
you say these things I think people are
starving for joy starving for joy like
whenever I've done anything on social
lately which by the way I just want to
give a shout out to your team because
I'm working with your team who's coming
around with me on tour we're having so
much goddamn fun and I've never been a
documented creating yeah but so I am
naturally goofy in life so yesterday I'm
in Orlando I'm dancing in the book store
in the airport because that's how I
really am I am NOT performing because
you saw your book in there yeah and then
I sold it to a woman saw me and she was
like what's this book and I said it's an
amazing book you should get it she's
like I will buy it right now I'm like
handy did you tell her tell her that it
was you yes because I've sold my book in
Hudson News
yes acting as if it wasn't me I need to
try that on our next stop because I feel
like it's big diff because I love the
merit of selling yeah I was like okay if
the person thinks it's me they're gonna
feel guilty to buy it yeah I have to see
if I can sell this as a customer like I
was just a human it was pretty funny I'm
gonna go in I'm the guy who destroyed my
name he's like what kind of [ __ ] name
is that I'm like oh man yeah so he's
super smart but you should get it and if
you get it yeah he did cuz I could sell
anything that's what I do well well I'll
tell you this I the first time I walked
into Barnes & Noble on Tuesday when it
came out and we did this amazing video
but this guy was like totally didn't
know what to make of me and I'm like you
should get this book and he's like no no
no I don't need anything in my life and
I was like alright fine I'll get the
next one anyway so I think people are
starving for joy understood starving
support like some example of exuberance
I got it and I think the second thing I
think people have to still pay really
close attention to how much they're
consuming versus creating understood so
I give people a mantra create before you
consume so
Scholz amazing all that stuff there's a
lot of info coming at us but if people
don't shift that ratio you know that's
so obviously something I'm passionate
about which is what's led me to deeply
spending a lot of time on parenting and
insecurity yep because that's why people
aren't creating yep they're worried
about how they look the word about a
comment they're worried about so much
which is [ __ ] I mean we're gonna be
here's the thing I said on tour the
other night I was like we're all gonna
be dead in a hundred years or less we're
gonna be powder you you have to stop
giving a [ __ ] what I'm really really
focused on being 144 so I'm trying to do
you think I don't seriously I was just
gonna no way I knew they might I do
think kids that are under 15 yeah have
scary numbers in their future in terms
of longevity yeah yeah I think I think
I'm real pissed if you're 14 right now
I'm super envious yeah cuz I think a
buck 50 is not out of the question
I agree I'm shooting on a 120 personally
what are you shooting for for real is it
100 because I think we're far like like
like we don't get the full benefits of
all the technology and science
advancements yeah our not you know we're
not 25 you and I said like I think 120 I
just don't think there's enough time
take away all the other things i but by
the way here's the good news I failed
all my science classes yeah I speak with
conviction on a lot of topics yeah I
have no [ __ ] idea what we're talking
about right now yeah I'm going on pure
intuition random headlines over hearing
much smarter people about science talk
than me
yeah I'm looking at my jeans too and on
my mom's side like Mike I was just with
my grandmother man she's a fireball
she's 98
- yeah CG yeah I believe in jeans and
with my jeans like I'm in trouble
like my mom sided family not so great
and like I'm bad and like I'm like [ __ ]
but I'm hoping resources I hope I can do
some weird like Walt Disney [ __ ] and
like freeze myself and then come out in
30 33 and be like [ __ ] I told
you I knew I was right it's all empathy
they're gonna come back with all right
let's do calls let's do call them let's
do cause what's up what's your favorite
social platform right now like where you
Instagram I'm having this I'm what
anything emerging have you made the
plunge in the tick-tock how you think
about link I was actually talking to
Witter like a tick-tock and I are just
gonna get acquainted today under Tom and
I huge like I think there's so much on
there which is hard internally so I want
to make sure every Power you
having fun with that are you just
everything just on it it's the only
platform has a chance to be the next
Instagram and so I take it seriously
yeah it's got vine
DNA Brittany its Gary Vaynerchuk how are
you on you're on with Murray another
point now where I'm totally you know
what my love I'm gonna interrupt you and
I'm so sorry for that but I want to get
to the answer because I know this so
well I would encourage you absolutely to
get that friggin job because when you're
busy and we're new you're hustling and
you have that money coming in you build
confidence and when you have confidence
you build all kinds of momentum so you
already bring value to the world by the
fact that you're alive now you're just
gonna amplify that by doing your work
and getting it out there in a bigger way
but I'll tell you if you're halfway
through your savings you don't want to
be dumb when it comes to your finances
and when it comes to building a whole
new career or a whole new business so
that's my own recommendation to you I
had side gigs for like seven years
before I was emotionally confident and
financially confident to go all-in on
what I wanted to do plus it was awesome
I met so many people so that's my
perspective on it Gary I don't know what
you want to say I'm a buyer of that
bread I think the thing to really think
about and I completely agree with Murray
and you see the practicality and that
answer I think the thing that is also
happening is the FET and I think this is
what we're both jumping on the fact that
you brought up within the first ten
words I'm halfway through my savings is
already a tell
for me like I'm a good poker player in
real life not an actual poker I already
now know that that's in your
subconscious so you're not able to go
all-in because you've got this little
thing going on in the back which I love
about you because you're being fully
practical you're not on some some
crystals gonna come out of a UFO and go
in my eye and I'm gonna solve the world
like you're you've got a good framework
I agree with Murray I'm gonna say
something else this is gonna collide
some of my worlds I love the idea and
this may not be in you but if it is one
of my favorite reasons of pushing people
to flip sports cards sneakers thrift
store garage sale things is the
following the reason I'd rather you make
$15 an hour buying t-shirts at a thrift
store or buying something at a dollar
store and selling it for 11 bucks is
because your biggest issue right now
potentially is figuring out how to
contain it create a container for your
value and then merchandise that
container to make dollars right and
what's amazing about flipping and eBay
and you know or you know all these
secondary offer up and Etsy and
Craigslist is you are required to figure
out the audience one of the things that
people don't understand is help how big
of a difference in value the reason you
see auction prices all over the place is
not just because of your rating on eBay
it's because how you wrote the headline
how you took the picture and the words
you put in it like there's a very
specific reason why I always sold things
on eBay better than my friends and
contemporaries is because I'm good at
positioning things and I feel like you
practicing flipping stuff may actually
help you figure out how to put yourself
into a container and merchandise it and
that skill set you pick up I think you
like to get good at sales and marketing
I think you have to do it the only
reason that I'm any good at what I do
and I have any success is because I
realized early on Britt that if I didn't
get just as good at sales and marketing
as I am at the craft of what I do which
is helping people create change I'm
[ __ ] dead in the water 100% yes or
you're limiting your upside
completely you know cuz a great product
will find its way out some level so
Brett I think I think also you're going
to a heady place right it's crippling to
think like I have value for the world
like what does that mean so two things I
definitely think you need to be making
money on the side cuz it's very clear to
me that that's an over lining issue and
number two anything that helps you buy
and sell it is the number one skill set
that 99% of my audience needs because
you're always doing it in one way or
another
does that make sense awesome good luck
thank you something with it thank you
you know it's funny as rug up goes the
next one that that buying and selling
thing really resonates to me yes because
even if you are resigned after seven
years I've wait a minute I'm not an
entrepreneur you're gonna have to sell
yourself to an employer like there's
like everybody should practice that
craft obviously like singing and
basketball and dancing some can
naturally do it yep but if you can get
better at it which you can get better at
anything yes it's one of the best things
to get good at and I think also
copywriting you mentioned writing
headlines everything yes who's this
Franklin got it
Franklin you're on with Marie Forleo how
are you really well what can we help you
with I mean I should Merson a question
with that last call but uh what I was
gonna ask is uh basically should I pay
somebody five to ten thousand dollars to
help me uh you know set up my business
model or should I just keep pumping out
content and pumping out car kids and
trying to strategically place it places
for it to you know get me to where I'm
trying to go yeah I think we should tell
you your business model here for free in
the next three minutes what are you
selling
basically personal development got it do
you have are you personally developed I
have been working on myself for the past
ten years and then are you are you that
are
you happy is [ __ ] fulfilled to the
oomph listen to this way I've made no
more than $600 this year and this has
been the happiest I've ever been my
entire life I love you already for that
why basically I have over and what it
really boils down to is because I'm
actually living a fulfilling purposeful
life and not feeling you know depressed
in all the negative things I'm actually
on a mission now and what not to do the
actions you've been doing that make you
say that what has been the actual
tangible day-to-day life that makes you
be able to say that I'm mostly the grind
just specifically because every day I
wake up and I feel you know empowered to
do something to get what I message out
there and you know past I would have
never I would have woke up and be like
you know another groggy day but nowadays
when I woke up I'm let's get it let's go
and I'll stay up till 2 3 o'clock in the
morning get two three hours sleep and
then after that I'm ready to go and you
okay Franklin I'm gonna dive in here
first of all congratulations on being
happier than you've ever been in your
life but there's a couple things I want
to I want to poke in and say one we're
not paying anyone ten or twelve or
fifteen thousand dollars to help figure
out your business model that is number
one you just got to think what is the
problem that I am helping people solve
and how am i doing it so are you selling
one-on-one coaching services are you
gonna sell a particular weekend
experience where you're teaching people
specific filt skills that help them
solve a specific problem you don't need
to worry about any of this paying other
children right yeah or because a lot of
people don't they like the idea of it
but they're not good at selling to other
people or like me don't want to do that
or are you gonna start a brand like life
is good do you have like a saying and
are you gonna slap 50 t-shirts together
with that saying post it on Instagram
and god forbid for some weird reason it
resonated and everybody bought it and
you might build an apparel business card
there's a lot of ways to do this you
shouldn't do in Murray's way or my way
you should do it your way
you know keep going yeah but absolutely
but we got to figure out what the
business model is you keep sharing your
message you keep doing that but you got
to do the work on your own to figure out
what is the business that you're gonna
have the best chance of being successful
at something that you're gonna want to
work morning's Nunes and nights and
weekends to make successful like Gary
said it could be an apparel company it
could be something completely different
but you just got to keep doing you but
business is separate I think than just
sharing a message out there a lot of
people want to quote-unquote monetize a
message I'm not into that [ __ ] doesn't
exist it does not exist and and and and
you need that like what how do you want
this is what I always ask people my
friend Franklin how do you want to make
money tell me that if if I was a genie
from the [ __ ] future how would you
like to make money you know I haven't
actually thought of that question I just
more or less was looking at it from you
know as long as I'm helping people
that's more fulfilling well there's a
bigger present listen to me that's a
hundred percent true yes and if you're
able for whatever reason to live on
making six hundred dollars a year then
[ __ ] you one I just want to make sure
that's the truth that's maybe you
inherited money maybe maybe you make ten
trillion before you started this maybe
maybe you're willing to couch-surf for
the rest of your life through people's
goodwill I just need to know that it's
sustainable well I would definitely
rather be making a lot more money than
six hundred dollars a year you know why
are you able to afford making six
hundred dollars a year because I is
somebody who pushes like eat [ __ ] you're
now challenging my [ __ ] Mendoza line cuz
I don't think I was talking about six
hundred dollars a year that's even
that's even shittier than [ __ ] like why
why are you did you save a lot of money
are you are you a trust fund baby like
help me here well basically what had
happened was me and my wife got a
divorce last third of Thanksgiving and
ever since then she important rod well I
know why you're so happy and there's no
I mean honestly which is great I'm not
making fun of the word and that's not
where I'm going I'm just saying that
might be that might be what a huge
factor while you're waking up every day
keep going
I'm sorry to jump in go ahead you could
basically we we switched roles she took
my traveling position and I'm now the
state-owned parent all the time so she
pays the bills and gives me like $100
wait to feed kids good for you and I've
been to Bobby have you I mean and the
parenting is massively fulfilling free
to you huh yeah good for you brother my
feel like good one I was just about to
say I'm with Gary I broke I apologize
Murray
broke I think you should flip [ __ ] nah
do you know have you seen any of this
content do you know what I'm saying
do you know that I think that I want you
to go to a thrift store right now look
up everything on eBay buy something for
four and sell it for 49 yeah have you
ever tried it I have it but are you
willing to detox yes I won't listen to
you say something about it two or three
days ago and I was talking to this girl
this is helping me you know I'm helping
build her and she's helping me grow also
Mal's telling her you know this is
probably one thing I'm gonna start doing
yes it's starting to pull out anyway
listen to me just make sure that
everything is practical and I think
you'll be okay I think you're good
you're in the starting phases of
something good just make sure that
ideology doesn't take over for execution
you have to do less what you're gonna do
yes less strategies more doing three
four days ago you see flipping works you
need it to be in a thrift store or
garage sale
you better garage sale this Saturday
frankly you better [ __ ] garage sale
tomorrow deal deal brother
so look bye I kind of want to start a
reality show on Franklin I feel like
that's how he'll actually make money
he's amazing all right let's do one more
before this is all wrapped up because we
are I mean because Dustin [ __ ] up
everything Dustin Dustin what the [ __ ]
Dustin look this poor guy he's like I do
sorry you guys Dustin you have to buy
like 4,000 copies of Murray's book
because we lost like that amount of time
and so now you have to personally buy
those Dustin you're in for it
everything is figure out a little
brother figure it out
hello Amanda how are you oh my god yes
you did it oh please say hello to Marie
Gary I love Marie I was a peaceful grad
two years ago yeah he's my life I make
50 grand with my first year consulting
it was a side gig and Carrie I listen to
you every day I can't believe this I do
you like better tell the truth we're
really I don't know emotional you're in
the Gary's go Marie I did nine new that
we do do you yeah here's why why first
of all I hung up on her
okay of all second of all second of all
you had you you had the tangible impact
you know like that like subconsciously
you Kate like it's I see it all the time
yeah like there's people who've loved
somebody for 27 years yeah
they see one video of mine that makes
them break up with a toxic boyfriend yes
and then that questions ask and they're
like Gary cuz it's the tit you know no I
know I miss goes to our whole theme yeah
execution actual stuff doing this is the
con this is why I do what I do it's
actually for people like her like when
people come through my program and
that's why I require that they do their
[ __ ] homework because of this because
when they actually take those actions
they get the results anybody who
actually does what I'm telling them to
do yes wins every time every to
everybody who uses it to make them feel
like they're doing something lose every
loses if they feel like they're
consuming my content to make them feel
like they're doing yeah cuz I'm doing so
much yes they lose yes now I don't mind
I'll be willing to be patient my big
fear my biggest concern right now in my
world yes is they watch me I then you
know I occasionally do the post where it
says stop [ __ ] watching me and go do
yep never listen to me again and go do
cuz I want them to win absolutely they
are not ready to do so what they do is
they unfollow me and what they do is
they go to a spam version of me and
consume that so I'm trying to figure out
my cadence with this because I'm trying
to get them to do yes you know what I
have an idea for you please
so hey stop listening to you right now
yeah go come this [ __ ] step and then
but but can you reward them somehow can
there be
necessarily even need them to come back
because I'm not necessarily I know that
I'm just scared if they go to the spam
version but you should but we need to
say that and I gotta say more I think it
everyone I I think it's super fun though
to have people go and do some [ __ ] and
then come back and [ __ ] talk about
you know why so they can get addicted to
the doing do you know what I think is
fun what Amanda yes I think Amanda's
dinner conversation in three weeks with
her friends is gonna be hilarious she's
like let me tell you what happened to me
a couple weeks ago yes miraculously
thousands thousands of phone numbers got
through to Gary Murray I love them both
so much yes Gary asked me this random
question I thought going with the truth
is always the right answer
yes nope sometimes you play Gary hangs
up with me and never ever do I have that
chance to speak to both of them again
that's life
you're always learning kids I'm gonna
randomly call you in a couple weeks to
make up for hanging up on you because
that doesn't feel good with me but it's
a fun way to end the show yes wait and
let's do you want to do I'll give away
for some fun [ __ ] stickers like
jersey Murray no more excuses
yes so I want to give away at least one
or two signed copies of everything as
bigger a double and here's why because I
believe that for anyone watching or
listening right now if there's any piece
of them that doesn't believe they have
what it takes here to do the thing that
they want to do if you like them to do
that um actually I'm gonna leave this up
to you guys because it's your platform
we we we will do a random but I have an
idea yeah a lot of different ways we're
definitely giving one to Amanda yes on
so can you personalize this one will
shirt and then we'll figure out a couple
we'll figure out another one and you can
get some stickers too so everything is
figure out a ball start before you're
ready is it this camera or which one
which was start before you're ready
there's a jersey Murray
no more [ __ ] excuses that's fun and
it's a Tropicana orange because this is
the thing that my mom is her most prized
possession in Jersey she got it for free
and it was the thing that she fixed that
got me this idea it was awesome thanks
for being on the show thank you for
thanks for everybody listening awesome
thank you